أجنبي
في لحظة في شخص يعاني من
توقف القلب يحتاج إلى مساعدة على الفور، لديك
خمس دقائق
لديك خمس دقائق من
إغماء الشخص إلى AED يعيد
الإيقاع الطبيعي قبل أن يحتمل أن تتعرض
لتلف في الدماغ تقول الدكتورة نعومي كورتيز من
مستشفى الأطفال الوطني إنها
ترى في كثير من الأحيان عواقب
عدم معرفة الأشخاص لما يجب عليهم فعله في
العام الماضي، لقد كان لدي مرضى
أغمي عليهم في المدرسة،
وكان جهاز AED قاب قوسين أو أدنى
لم يستخدمه أحد وتوفي الطفل ولهذا
السبب تقول إنه من المهم معرفة ثلاثة
أشياء قبل  في حالات الطوارئ المتعلقة بالسكتة القلبية،
يحتاج الأشخاص أولاً إلى الوصول إلى
أجهزة إزالة الرجفان الخارجية الآلية حتى يمكن
استخدامها، ويحتاجون أيضًا إلى أن يكونوا قادرين على الوصول
إليها بسرعة، كما يقول كورتيز، في غضون
دقيقتين من أي مكان في المبنى،
أخيرًا، يحتاج الأشخاص إلى معرفة كيفية استخدام
AED  تشعر بالراحة عند نزعه من
الحائط ووضعه على المريض،
وتقول إن الجهاز سيقوم بالباقي في
اللحظة التي يفقد فيها شخص ما وعيه ولا
يستيقظ، يجب على شخص ما الاتصال بالرقم 9-1-1،
ويجب على شخص ما إجراء الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي ويجب على
شخص ما الحصول على  أن AED
قد يكون الشخص في حالة توقف القلب إذا
انهار فجأة وفقد الوعي ولا
يتنفس أو يلهث من أجل الهواء ولا
يستجيب للصراخ أو الاهتزاز أو إذا
لم يكن لديه نبض يقول كورتيز إن
إجراء التدريبات كل عام يمكن أن يساعد في الحصول على
الناس مستعدون فقط في حالة الصحة
الدقيقة أنا آندي غايثر
أجنبي